fühlen sie sich gerade auch so herbst
2020 in der zeitschleife gefangen ich
kann nur für mich sprechen ich fühle
mich so denn wer ist wieder da und war
in wirklichkeit auch nie richtig weg
nach
corona ja leider diese woche ein
allzeithoch bei den neuinfektionen und
auch die intensivstationen laufen
langsam voll er hat uns also schon
wieder überrascht dieser verdammte
herbst wer konnte das hier wie nennt man
das noch wenn ein land immer wieder die
selben fehler macht doof richtig ja wir
sind eindeutig zu doof meine es war doch
völlig klar wie sich die gewaltige im
pflücke in deutschland auswirken würde
trotzdem haben fast alle impfzentren zum
ersten oktober dicht gemacht nur zwei
millionen deutsche wurden bereits
gepustet und dank der üblichen
kakophonie zwischen stiko bund und
ländern blickt in sachen dritte impfung
jetzt wirklich keine sau mehr tue ich ja
das haben wir geschafft hier jens spahn
zum beispiel sagt sinngemäß boostern für
alle beziehungsweise wussten boostern
mustern einen huf dafür alle lehnt die
stiko derzeit ab alle älteren als 70
sollten jetzt eine auffrischimpfung
erhalten mertins ordnung hat aber jeder
ab zwölf jahren das recht auf eine
dritte impfung heißt bei hausärzten
keine dritte impfung für jüngere mehr
kriegt den booster und wo
beziehungsweise von nehmen es ist mir
ehrlich gesagt total egal
eventuell ein bisschen böswillig
geschnitten das ende kann sein so wir
fassen kurz zusammen die dritte spritze
kriegen alle erwachsenen minderjährigen
über 70 oder so ähnlich dabei ist
boostern vor allem für ältere mitbürger
offensichtlich eine frage von leben und
tod ja da geht es nicht nur darum unser
weihnachten zu retten also auch unser
weihnachten zu retten klar klar
israel hat mit postern die vierte welle
gebrochen bei uns sterben schon wieder
menschen in altenheimen wo zum teil die
hälfte des personals um geimpftes
machst du nichts denn impfpflicht für
pflegepersonal geht halt nicht weil die
ungeimpften sonst kündigen oder traurig
sind ich habe keine ahnung wer kann ich
jetzt endlich mal ne wohlfühl nachricht
hören es gibt ein absolutes ende aller
maßnahmen und alle maßnahmen enden
spätestens mit dem frühlingsbeginn am 20
märz
wussten sie dass
zum frühlingsanfang endet corona weil es
ist ja frühling
ich hoffe das virus kriegt das memo am
20 märz ist freedom day sagt die ampel
und dann singt david hasselhoff vor dem
brandenburger tor looking for freedom
day das wird fantastisch werden übrigens
mit einer besseren impfquote hätten wir
längst unseren freedom day geht aber
nicht bei allein 3,2 millionen
ungeimpften über 60 die spannende frage
ist wie viele von denen kann man noch
irgendwie umstimmen und noch wichtiger
wie viel druck ist da erlaubt wenn es
sogar ein lockdown nur für ungeimpfte
ist ja schon im gespräch da man könnte
noch weiter gehen und sagen der
ungeimpfte muss nicht nur zu hause
bleiben ihm wird automatisch netflix
gesperrt stattdessen laufen auf allen
kanälen nur noch wiederholungen der
heute show
o
so die dürfen zwar noch pizza bestellen
aber ganz wichtig die quattro stagioni
wird grundsätzlich kontaktlos zu stehen
und vor dem fenster jedes unbewussten
steht den ganzen tag einer vom
gesundheitsamt mit einem laubbläser
okay es geht vielleicht ein bisschen zu
weit zugegeben so und während bei uns
nur diskutiert und gestritten wird macht
unser nachbar österreich doch vor 3g am
arbeitsplatz wirklich kontrollieren
fertig italien macht dasselbe in allen
öffentlichen innenräumen und hat
überraschung eine deutlich bessere
impfquote
auch wenn bei den italienern offenbar
nicht alle impfpässe hundertprozentig
korrekt sind in italien tauchte jetzt
wie zum beweis ein im qr code auf der
auf den namen adolf hitler ausgestellt
ist tatsächlich bestätigt auch die chep
der code ist echt erlebt
gut für für rechtsextreme für nazis ist
das ein echtes dilemma überlegen sie mal
die freuen sich dass hitler lebt auf der
anderen seite ist dagegen
der führer hört auf drosten
verräter so wir sind uns einig nur
impfen bringt die normalität zurück umso
bedrückender werden sämig informierte
promis ihr zweifel verstärken sie
bestimmt gelesen zuletzt am wagenknecht
und richard david precht ich weiß jetzt
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr wer hat
was gesagt hat ich meine dass
verschwimmt ja alles zu zu einem schwabl
im grunde ja im fall von frau
wagenknecht musste übrigens der arme
karl lauterbach bei anne will eine
stunde lang daneben sitzen war ganz
unterhaltsam sollte man öfter sehen
wagenknecht und lauterbach der neue
podcast von wagenknecht und lauterbach
sie redet wird und er muss zuhören
der schützt in erster linie sich selbst
und man sollte das nicht moralisch als
ein akt der solidarität mit anderen auf
glas und london wird sie wissen bisher
lauterbach ist umstritten irgendwann
fangen wir an
[Musik]
zumal auch das ist ja irgendwann
vielleicht mit künftigen erkrankungen
verbunden von außen gar nichts
also wir sollten mal darüber nachdenken
was betrunken
ist und lauterbach absolut unhörbar
wieso ist ein gutes team oder ich würde
das hören ernsthaft haben sie frau
wagenknecht zugehört longo wird gibt's
gar nicht falls sie also demnächst nach
luft ringend die treppe hoch schleichen
das bilden sie sich alles nur ein und
von wegen impfen nur für einen selber
hallo ich denke mein risiko für einen
schweren verlauf drastisch ja und
entlastet damit krankenhäuser und
pflegepersonal sei logisch
wagenknecht ist politikerin precht
philosoph was immer das sein mag kann
ich bitte mal einen echten experten
hören da melden sich jeder und jeder
wieder
da haben es wurst weiß jetzt irgendwie
von der politik oder von von den
forschern und von den ärzten jeder weiß
und gibt seinen senf dazu und das ist
alles so ja so genau
ja vielen dank professor poldi
nächste woche fragen wir ihn nach dem
nahostkonflikt ich freue mich schon
heute wirklich ich kann es nicht mehr
ertragen ich kann es nicht mehr hören
dieses ewige werde ich mich nicht impfen
lassen ist dass beide privatsache ja
eben nicht leute privatsache ist wenn
ich mir zum beispiel einen hohen
piercing stechen lassen ja mit dem süßen
heute-show logo dran
das ist ohne frage schmerzhaft und dumm
weil ich so was oft entzündet
aber ich schade keinem andern so wenn
ich mich jetzt aber spontan entscheiden
dem studiopublikum einen hohen pc zu
zeigen
so und daraufhin wird die sendung völlig
zurecht abgesetzt und 50 von meinen
leuten verlieren ihren job dann ist das
nicht mehr meine privatsache oder
anderes beispiel wenn ihr mich nicht
impfen lasse und so dazu beitragen dass
bald herz-op es von geimpften verschoben
werden ist das keineswegs privat sondern
leider irgendwie asozial es ist doch
nicht so schwer zu kapieren leute das
corona comeback und ulkiger zufall
morgen beim großen wetten dass comeback
gibt es gleich mehrere tolle corona
außenwetten präsentiert vom neuen
außenreporter giovanni zarella gerade
laufen die proben in nürnberg giovanni
worauf dürfen wir uns denn da freuen
oliver es ist ein traum wetten dass ist
zurück die legende hier bei rtl
nach beim zdf noch besser und da sehe
ich auch schon die wunderbare michelle
hunziker
liebe zuschauer ich bin wieder zu hause
wetten dass alles wie früher
auch schauen sie mal da drüben ist ein
alter obdachloser mann hat nur einen
bademantel und eine billige perry kann
das ist traurig giovanni das ist thomas
gottschalk
tommy
du musst leider sprechen michael er
macht jetzt werbung für hörgeräte
wir zeigen dir unsere wunderbaren
außenwetten genau das team for kids
zentrum nürnberg wettet dass es in nur
drei minuten ihr eigentlich
geschlossenes zentrum wieder aufbauen
kann sagt jens spahn es so will stopp
stopp stopp stopp ich höre gerade die
gesundheitsminister der länder sagen
dass im zentrum bleibt doch zu also
alles wieder abbauen sofort
stop stop kommando zurück jetzt sparen
sagt sofort wiederaufbau du merkst du
lieber super spannend auch unsere zweite
außen betteln
kein wetten dass ohne bagger wette der
69 jährige manfred hier träumt von einer
booster impfung genau arbeit die stiko
sagt booster nur für 70 und da hat er
manfred gesagt die stiko kann mich mal
ja und deswegen hat manfred schwaiger
haben und jetzt genau eine minute zeit
den manfred mit dieser
angeordnete befestigten spritze zu
impfen und um es interessanter zu machen
giovanni wir sind hier bei wetten dass
der hartmut hat in seinem ganzen leben
noch nie auf einem bagger geschossen
also top die wette gilt
bisher müssen wir ein bisschen höher und
jedes langsamer die für jeden etwas
tiefer tiefer
schade
giovanni zarrella und michelle hunziker
[Applaus]
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
ein leichter last
ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da